who scares you more Donald Trump or Ted
Cruz
well Cruz has just announced that one of
his foreign policy advisers is the guy
who's been described as having paranoid
fantasies about Muslims destroying the
West from within that's Frank Gaffney
who served in Ronald Reagan's defense
department and runs a think tank called
the Center for security policy which by
the way the Southern Poverty Law Center
calls a hate group when Trump called for
banning Muslims in America he used one
of the center's dubious studies which
tend to be about secret Muslim plans for
dominating the United States Gaffney is
the little obsessed with that theory
according to him
Muslims are pretty far along with their
plot for example Gaffney insists that
the u.s. government is infiltrated at
the highest levels by secret Muslim
operatives even up to the level of the
President himself other influential
secret Muslims bringing down the country
from within long-term Hillary Clinton
aide Huma Abedin an anti-tax
conservative grover norquist yeah that
guy Gavin I see signs of the Islamic
dominance of America everywhere that new
missile defense agency logo there's an
Islamic crescent right there logos
aren't the only thing that terrified
gaffney refugees due to he's got a
theory that the left is coaching Muslims
around the world on how to look like
refugees so they can infiltrate every
neighborhood in the United States
according to him Muslims have already
conquered Dearborn Michigan he's called
it Dearborn Aston and suggested it's too
dangerous to go to last year Gaffney
hosted white supremacist Jared Taylor on
his radio show and praised his work
after Hurricane Katrina hit New Orleans
Taylor had said that when blacks are
left entirely to their own devices
Western civilization and any kind of
civilization disappears Frank Gaffney is
so delusional that he was at one point
banned from CPAC the most prominent
conference for the conservative movement
in the United States they brought him
back this year though and in the last
year alone Ted Cruz Ben Carson Carly
Fiorina Mike Huckabee and Rick Santorum
who were all running for president have
spoken at his events everyone gets
worked up over Trump's Islamophobia but
what does it say about the GOP when
someone like Gaffney is a top advisor
for their second leading candidate